>> DOING SPORTS TOGETHER IS
AWESOME.
>> TOTALLY.
I'M THIRSTY.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> WHOA!
HE JUST BURST THROUGH THE WALL.
>> WHO WANTS KOOL-AID?
>> I AM.
SLAP ME SOME SKIN.
OH, YEAH.
>> I WANT TO BE LIKE KOOL-AID.
>> IS THIS A KOOL-AID MAN?
>> OH, YEAH.
>> MORE LIKE OH, NO.
>> WHO'S THIRSTY FOR SOME
KOOL-AID.
DRINK UP.
>> WE CAN'T LAUGH IT OFF.
>> WE DON'T EVEN WANT KOOL-AID.
>> MAKING THE SAME OLD EXCUSES.
>> OH, YEAH!
>> IT'S BEEN GOING ON FAR TOO
LONG.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> OH, YEAH!
>> YOU TELL THEM, SON.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> BUT SOMETHING FINALLY
CHANGED.
>> THE KOOL-AID MAN IS IN HOT
WATER AFTER ALLEGATIONS OF
BURSTING THROUGH WALLS.
[ TALKING OVER EACH OTHER ]
>> BUSTED, AND THERE WILL BE NO
GOING BACK.
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IN THE BEST
IN A KOOL-AID MAN.
TO SAY THE RIGHT THING.
>> NO, NO, NO, NO, NO MAN.
>> NOT COOL.
>> AND TO ACT THE RIGHT WAY.
>> YOU GOT TO KNOCK FIRST, AND
THEN ASK IF YOU CAN ENTER, OKAY,
BUD?
>> ALL RIGHT, DAD.
>> I DIDN'T REALIZE YOU WERE
DOING SOMETHING IMPORTANT.
>> SORRY.
OKAY, WELL AS I WAS SAYING --
>> TIMES ARE CHANGING.
>> BECAUSE THE KOOL-AID BOYS
WATCHING TODAY WILL BE THE
KOOL-AID MEN OF TOMORROW.
>> WHO'S THIRSTY FOR SOME
KOOL-AID?
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]